[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy desentrañar hemos el pasado
por el cual armenia y azerbaiyán se
encuentran en estado de guerra por
nagorno karabaj a este fue el momento el
25 de diciembre de 1991 en el que la
bandera roja de la unión soviética fue
arriada para siempre
habían discurrido siete décadas en las
cuales quince repúblicas socialistas se
habían agrupado forzosamente por la
represión comunista sobre jason roberts
de hc aprox buenas noches precisamente
hace dos horas mijail gorbachov hizo una
declaración en vivo por televisión y
hace dos horas precisamente anunció que
renunciaba a sus funciones de presidente
de la urss
aquí está su declaración
sangras billing compatriotas
conciudadanos como resultado de la
situación actual así se abrazaban satrus
stuart y tras la creación de los estados
independientes renunció a mis funciones
como presidente de la urss o un apuesto
presidente que se cerró según andrei
riábov del carnegie center en moscú la
independencia de la urss fue una carga
muy pesada para muchos de los estados ex
soviéticos estaban las repúblicas
bálticas estonia letonia y lituania las
repúblicas eslavas ucrania rusia y
bielorrusia las repúblicas
centroasiáticas y las repúblicas
caucásicas georgia armenia y azerbaiyán
estas últimas repúblicas del cáucaso
entraron en una serie de conflictos
territoriales explicado por la
multiplicidad de etnias y por los
intereses geopolíticos de rusia y de
turquía el cáucaso tierra de montañas
comprendida entre el mar negro y el mar
caspio entre europa del este y asia
occidental es el hogar de más de 50
etnias con sus propios idiomas culturas
y formas de pensamiento
las tres más grandes agruparon los
pueblos de los georgia nos los armenios
y los azerbayanos o hace diez pueblos
milenarios que fueron absorbidos tanto
por el imperio de los zares rusos como
por el imperio de los turcos otomanos
pero con la primera guerra mundial que
dictaba el final del imperio turco y del
imperio ruso las naciones del cáucaso
atisbaron una independencia que sólo se
trató de un espejismo según el libro
etnicidad nacionalismo y conflicto en el
sur del cáucaso escrito por hoja nes
jawzjan los bolcheviques y los turcos
jugaron un rol decisivo en el destino
del actual conflicto entre armenia y
azerbayán aquí entra el actualmente
renombrado territorio de nagorno karabaj
a este antiguo enclave mayormente
poblado por armenios con una religión en
su mayoría cristiana ortodoxa fue cedido
en 1921 a la vecina república soviética
de azerbaiyán por iniciativa de josef
stalin
así lo narra lebón chorbadjian en su
libro la creación de nagorno karabaj
cuando explica que stalin al ver la
lucha enconada entre las fuerzas
armenias turcas y azeríes actuó sobre la
base de conveniencia política según sor
vayan la política de stalin de unir
nagorno karabaj a azerbayán debería
haberse dentro del contexto de la
cooperación soviético turca y la forma
en que los bolcheviques mantuvieron su
influencia en el cáucaso lo cierto es
que esta decisión de stalin fue un
desafío a la historia y son tres los
argumentos que confirman esta tesis en
el libro la creación de nagorno karabaj
a primero hay asentamientos armenios
documentados en el cáucaso que datan de
hace más de dos milenios segundo la
demografía de nagorno karabaj para 1921
estaba compuesta con más del 90% de
población armenia y tercero el deseo de
los residentes siempre ha sido ser parte
de armenia de manera que ser cedidos a
azerbayán una tierra musulmana chiíta
constituyó la más grande afrenta en su
historia reciente
esta puja entre armenia y azerbaiyán
estuvo congelada hasta finales de la
década de 1980 cuando las reformas de
gorbachov dejaron a las repúblicas
soviéticas a su propia suerte y fue en
1988 cuando estas reformas del glasnot
fueron puestas a prueba en febrero de
ese año
armenia experimentó grandes
movilizaciones en una escala jamás antes
vista desde que la urss se formó en 1920
las manifestaciones de cerca de un
millón de armenios se tomaron las calles
y clamaron por el retorno de nagorno
karabaj a yereván la capital armenia
cargo durante meses de huelgas la
esperanza de que gorbachov y su política
el glass mode permitieran corregir una
injusticia histórica pero guardan chof
no actúa a favor de armenia dadas las
circunstancias y la decepción armenia
del partido comunista los armenios
libraron una dolorosa guerra contra
azerbaiyán que duró hasta 1994 cuando se
decretó un cese del fuego pero no se
llegó a ningún otro acuerdo más que
deponer las armas a nagorno karabaj
no le quedó otra
y va que autoproclamarse independiente y
armenia fue bloqueada comercialmente por
turquía y azerbaiyán desde entonces y
por cerca de 25 años muchas
multinacionales occidentales invirtieron
en la extracción de petróleo y gas
natural en azerbayán con lo cual este
país se volvió rico y poderoso en armas
de última tecnología en contraparte
armenia no ha tenido el mismo desarrollo
acd y se muestra en una clara desventaja
militar a su favor está en la
determinación histórica las montañas que
lo protegen y un supuesto apoyo ruso la
ausencia de un acuerdo de paz definitivo
ha contribuido a exacerbar las tensiones
regionales en el cáucaso con explosiones
tan violentas como las que se viven
actualmente un abismo hacia una larga
guerra abierta entre armenia y azerbayán
así concluimos hoy andrés suárez
jaramillo gracias por compartir estas
historias que las encuentran en france
24 punto com
[Música]